All right, so here is the example. Okay, if this is just for example, I don't know the context behind this move
I'm just showing you that that how it can work. Okay, so you see we have lower low lower high lower low, okay
So now these consecutive bearish candles are
In alignment with this breaker block. You can see that right
The body the size of the bodies is the same here, okay, and then you can see that we
Have a push down
so these are consecutive bearish candles because
This bearish candle did not take out the low here
So if if this bearish candle took out this low then that would be my auto block
Okay, and this green candle would have become a breaker block
Do you understand what I'm trying to say here? So as you can see we had there the setup here
We could have taken our entry from this level put our shot right below the slope and went for one to two or
For this high over here
It's really all that guys like simply you can take your entries see if you use the old method
Right remember the first candle of the fair valley gap, which is right here. You would have missed your entry guys
So this is this is what I'm trying to teach you in this video
Okay, you must know
You must have like a plan you have to choose one model entry model, okay?
You either stick with the the old method or the new one. It's really up to you. Okay, so
Yeah, guys, I'll see you guys in the next video